[Musique]
le village corail accueille pendant
trois jours les 4 5 et 6 octobre les
manifestations proposées dans le cadre
de la journée nationale des aidants le
statut de proche aidant c'est quelqu'un
ça peut être un membre de la famille
comme ça peut être un voisin ou un ami
qui va effectivement accompagné une
autre personne
malades en situation de handicap ou
âgées dans des actes essentiels de la
vie quotidienne elle va l'aider dans ses
déplacements elle va l'aider à
s'alimenter elle va l'aider à se changer
donc c'est vraiment un rôle qui est
qui est dédié vraiment à l'approché
danse ils y sont 50000 proches aidants à
la réunion à s'occuper d'un proche au
quotidien un engagement lourd qui
souvent isole les dents se retrouvant
ainsi en manque d'accompagnement et de
soutien moralement parce que notre santé
pour un coup parce que lui il était
vraiment de grabataires moi je me suis
donné à fond à froidfond mais maintenant
je veux dire donc au le moral pour un
coût et puis des fois on n'est pas bien
on envie de explosé on a envie d'y aller
mais on peut pas devant le malin devant
le patient va venir
on essaye de garder le sourire on essaye
de faire en sorte qu on est on est mieux
en lançant t'es mais au fond de
nous-mêmes défendre les pauvres non plus
on a besoin d'autres personnes pour
iliad écoute tu as besoin d'un coup de
main à une épaule et aux autres c'est ça
mais des fois c'est pas le cas on est
tout seul face aux sur situation et
c'était difficile
alors pendant trois jours leur sont
consacrés des ateliers des changes des
séances de bien-être et des stands
d'informations avec le groupement
d'intérêt public services à la personne
le département s'engage à apporter un
peu de repos et de répit à ses proches
aidants département proposons de
dispositifs une pour en faveur des
aidants donc c'est la maison des aidants
qui se situe à l'antre-2 donc permet aux
aidants de venir sur sur cette journée
profiter des moments de répit à travers
des ateliers de bien être de la
formation des groupes des changes et on
propose également donc au niveau de
saint denis donc la maison de répit de
la providence qui a été inauguré donc en
octobre de l'année dernière on propose
effectivement aux aidants de pouvoir
confier leurs proches à une équipe de
professionnels soit sur deux sur la
journée ou sur eux sur une semaine nous
on a mis en place par exemple le pass
bien-être qui a été reconduit qui nous
permet de donner des moyens financiers
aux personnes aux aidants ou ajustements
se reçoit s'est retrouvé un peu de
bien-être dans se passe bien être c'est
un moyen ou en place par le département
et au delà tabac les répits repos tout
un ensemble de dispositifs mais je sais
que les aidants veulent plus
avoir un statut disposer d'un véritable
statut mais là c'est un combat qu'on
doit mener et je les soutiens là dedans
dans ce combat-là auprès du gouvernement
et bien sûr auprès des parlementaires
pour que le statut des aidants soit
mieux reconnu un statut de pro chez don
qui manque encore de reconnaissance pour
leur engagement quotidien en mai 2015
l'état leur reconnaît un droit au répit
un premier pas vers le changement
[Musique]